quiet calm and nearly empty this is an
unfamiliar scene that is quickly
becoming the new normal
Hamad International Airport in Doha is
usually one of the busiest airports in
the Middle East but now because of the
covert 19 pandemic operations are
running at an all-time low the global
health crisis has changed the way things
operate here due to this global change
of course there's a big downsizing of of
the operation currently what's what's
happening and of course we had to adapt
organizationally and also our processes
and disinfect ation standards
the airport is disinfected twice a day
for now only Qatari citizens are allowed
back into the country and they are
tested for Koba 19:00 upon arrival Qatar
Airways had about 250 flights a day now
that's down to around 75 with mainly
transit flights through Doha and
passengers must pass through these
thermal scanners which measure their
body temperature the planes which are
still flying are being disinfected after
each flight and according to staff here
they are fitted with a special
ventilation filter I can't advise you
that Qatar Airways has one of the most
modern fleets in the air our aircraft
have got very good air filtration
systems onboard and we've got an
enhanced cleaning procedure for all our
aircraft while most airlines in this
part of the world have stopped their
passenger flights Qatar Airways remains
operational for now and Qatar Airways
believes that the future of air travel
will largely rely on more testing of
passengers what we're aiming to do is to
use newly developed immunoassay test
kits which give you an instant answer
what an answer within 10 minutes but at
the moment these are still fairly new
they're still in development but we've
already put an order in for a
significant number of these kits that we
can test our cruise and our arrived
passengers as Qatar Airways continues
its travel restrictions some transit
passengers are still trying to make
their way home in uncertain times this
airport served more than 38 million
passengers last year but now this is how
things look 40% of the workforce here
have been told to work from home while
the Health Ministry imposes strict
measures on the Qataris that are
returning from abroad and other
passengers who pass through for now what
is certain is that the effects of this
pandemic on the travel industry will be
felt for years to come Dora Jabari al
Jazeera Hamad International Airport Doha